I've actually never been on a blind date
with you
[Music]
I don't have feelings for Mauro yes I
did have some slight feelings for her
getting it out would you decide to see
either of those guys again
[Music]
[Music]
Belzer boo kill the bill
build a boo-boo-boo-boo-boo and if he
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Merle I'm 27 years
old and I am a video producer here at
BuzzFeed
I am Corki I am adventurous and I'm
sweet I have for a long time been in
relationship after relationship after
relationship I needed time on my own but
I will say I've been doing some serious
self exploring and it's been wonderful
being singles nice but at the end of the
day it's nice to have someone to sleep
thanks to and like to go to the movies
with I like cuddling perfect guy okay
300 right thank you you can see it I was
like let me give you my TED talk smart
funny unpredictable the perfect first
date we don't eat I don't like to eat in
front of people when I don't know them
right away I'd like to do something I'd
like to go do something so I'm maybe
hiking
I know Joyce and Joyce is a wizard so
I'm expecting she's gonna set me up with
some people that are gonna offer me
great conversation a memorable
experience whether we end up together or
not and at the end of the day I just
want a good story alright I'm excited
for these dates I'm ready for Joyce to
set me up let's do this thing so long I
found four different guys I'm Angelo
Joshua Dylan
and then lastly Aria what oh yeah you
know your desk mate already for BuzzFeed
I feel like I've is an intervention
right now I at least look at what these
other guys look like please of course
can someone please bring me my laptop
this is Dylan he's been single for about
seven to eight months this he spent the
last year enjoying his time being single
dated and had plenty of relationships
next is Michael he's 24 he's a little
young as someone who tends to be really
creative and goofy like people with a
similar energy definitely a bright actor
smile okay so next we have aria
so I know this mania you do work with
this maniac I'm gonna cross wonderful
picture for me going I do like the be
done so what I like about art is that he
is a really sweet person and he has this
deep darkness with him that he doesn't
understand so they always surprise you
my goodness
he had a long-term relationship I broke
up and then I started dating kind of a
way in bio but it's very familiar
I don't know him right um you've
probably seen them in a BuzzFeed video
called a best European accent what is
this worldly living and he was mr. d
mr. Griese so now that you've seen all
the choices I'm going to call in a wait
show your bestie and we're gonna sign
into DMS on your phone watch please hand
your phone that was that part of this
Agreement yep please a new phone Rachel
over here uh so this is my phone okay I
already have the instagrams ready so
we're just gonna slide into the dams as
hurry okay and you're her bestie so yeah
I can't have her out here in these
streets me in a while you know okay and
I'm Abajo
I'm curious see you peg so first up is
daddy gently he looks like he goes to a
lot of music festivals
okay so Morel went to lightning in a
bottle last year and she can't stop
talking about it it's like her favorite
music festival of all time so she could
ask him if he's ever been to lightning
in a bottle
oh well that's cute - have you ever been
to lightning in a bottle because I want
to go with you
like a mosaic emoji half smile a smile
emoji is the most effectual emoji to me
and you can put all the fruits and
vegetables you want well when you drop
that half smile on my oh yeah imma bust
your windows okay so that's just Joshua
he's a nice oh yeah
[Applause]
but he has a good body in a nice way
he just went to LA so I'm gonna put I
here in me to the city I'm gonna explore
it with me for the city explore other
things um yeah okay what a mochi I'm
probably gonna do the half smirk emoji
polish so evangelist is he's like oh
okay
evangelist those are some so I can see
them from a mile away
yeah I'm saying in the apocalypse oh
I'll wash all my clothes oh sweet and
beautiful and let's let's do it you know
what do we have to lose I'm gonna tell
him you could whisper in my ear whatever
you want
smile emoji wink emoji sheriff geology I
teach the youth well so next we're gonna
go to our last person okay you might
know him oh yeah oh yeah
okay there is definitely some pent-up
tension going on between these two
I mean it's obvious it needs to be
explored
yeah for sure what should we put in our
SDM hike with me loser and let's grab a
drink
boink emoji I like it I like it son so
we got a reply back oh that was fast
from a panel okay
Evangel oh so definitely I think we're
gonna set up the date with him okay
and I think Ari's gonna reply like
probably five hours from now because
it's probably editing but you can't
pretend you didn't see it but oh please
oh but is this and say you're going on a
date so these seem like two good
candidates I think it's time for our
class of jingle hey my name is
cementerio de I'm 26 years old I'm so
excited that I gonna meet Mauro I
brought it here to Museum of usual it's
gonna be really cool let's let's see
what's gonna happen
am i with my first date with Eve Angelo
so I'm all nervous
I've actually never gone on a blind date
so this is a new experience
and we're gonna just have to see how
this goes
I'm going through museum volusion's
sounds really cool right up my alley I
like weird stuff so I'm just I go into
it with an open mind cuz Joyce told me
to and hope for the best
hey how are you nice to meet you I love
your hat ah Hollywood because you know I
try to find a really cool place I like
weird things so like you picked you did
a good job
are you worried yes two months probably
let's see okay this is the first round
nice ah beautiful you have a semi-rural
you know
Wow you fit right in
give us a little walk give us a little
spin
know you're famous for sure for sure for
sure my thoughts are really really nice
very nice guy obviously super super
attractive when I first saw him I was
like maybe he's kind of a little bit of
a I don't know like playboy or sometimes
however very nice seems very genuine he
like wants to have fun but to be
completely honest I think I need to like
slow down a little bit I feel like I'm
rushing and I'm rushing through this a
little bit and I'm like not letting
myself kind of relax and enjoy I'm gonna
just try to like for the rest of this
have some fun just let it go like what's
what's the big deal what's the worst
thing that could happen
[Music]
I'm really having fun the girls is
pretty interesting person and you know I
want to explore here more if you want
coffee or drink I love to do have a
drink with here
[Music]
the day it was really good she's a
beautiful girl
this is really kinda girl so I love to
make sure again to have a drink or
coffee or something
let's see if she gonna okay so I just
finished on my first date
I had a good time he's really sweet I
don't know necessarily if I feel like
the electricity
ah today's hard dating is hard fill the
pool enjoy
[Music]
little too worked in a day and I've been
told that today's the day I'll be taking
Morel out on our our first date
courtesy of Joyce I don't know if Morel
actually knows that's gonna be a fun
surprise for her
so I heard that she went on a date
already with this other man a Greek
model I heard he has a six-pack that's
fine that's right what he doesn't have
is the months that I've spent across
from Merle talking with her getting no
work done I'm gonna use that knowledge
of her and what she likes to my
advantage and I know she likes hikes
Merle and I have a great time together
and I don't like the idea of some other
men taking her out and so I'm going to
have to just really up it today the more
pics other guy I won't lie I will be
quite devastated walking up to Runyon
Canyon to go on my hiking David Aria
I've never been on a date with Arya I
don't know what to expect but I'm just
trying to be open-minded about it we're
pretty snarky with each other so I guess
I'll try to minimize the snarkiness but
I can't make any promises yeah I think
it's me fun this is very awkward that
we're calling this a date for some
reason calling it a date makes it feel
20 times more intense oh my got it thank
you discuss recognized at the park I see
giving someone a hug
[Music]
all right so this other man he
apparently has a six-pack what does that
even mean they stack the odds against me
they stack the odds against me
it feels nice to be outside with aria
I feel you know I could run if I need to
there's people around but ultimately
honestly we're just having fun like
talking about other people that were
walking by I'm trying to introduce them
to the the beauty of nature which
doesn't really appreciate I feel very
comfortable buddy we have made to the
top yet so he if there's still time for
him to ruin it you're feisty
you're like an action figure you've got
a that way that was worth her word so
when she saw me come out of the out for
my fight all right it's got a sweet ass
oh that is very true it's been it's been
interesting it's been good it's it's
weird I've had fun
that's and I'm it's a little awkward you
know having having cameras around so you
know usually Merle and I are quite we're
quite goofy it's been very very nice you
know being outside of the office we have
a great time together today we're having
a great time together I don't have
feelings for Merle at the same time
though I know she want to date with some
other guy for this video and I don't
like that so we are we're getting in
there we're pretty much at the end of
the stairs yeah
[Music]
yeah give you this one great done with
the hike now I was ready to go home but
then arose like you know what we should
we should get a what she's gonna drink
or something you know the highway she
was short for her be fun we could have
yes it's been a long workday it has
about P for the meal
wrap it up morose very very sad at this
date is ending
I don't want to go surprisingly a good
time because I mean I knew it was gonna
be a good time yes I do have some slight
feelings for her but the fact that we
literally sit across from each other has
always been a big problem for me
hey even beyond that right not only are
we quarters but we're also just good
friends
Merle and I clearly have a lot of
chemistry I don't know if she will pick
me over the other guy but I guess I kind
[Music]
this was just so much fun it was so easy
and it felt really natural I've been
pushing this away for a really long time
and yeah the stubborn pardon he hates to
even admit if people were right about
Ariane me but so Merle
how was the date okay I had fun I had a
lot of fun okay I'm happy you did a very
good job you know I tried yeah yeah I
know I can tell and I see what you're up
to
Missy's I mean a little evil okay uh
first date with Eve Angela he was very
tall he was smelled like Ralph Lauren 3
and he took me to the Museum of
illusions oh that's really nice he's
gonna cool I mean a Hollywood Boulevard
is not my favorite place in the world
but it was a really different idea like
yeah I have never her first date that
was like I've written original and we
had fun yeah so I had a good time with
him but I didn't feel like I didn't feel
the same yeah
another thing my next one's gonna be
with aria
so I'm like alright so I've been
actively trying to avoid in going on a
date with Aria because we work together
so I feel like when we were forced it
kind of gave a freedom to like enjoy it
and not be like either it wasn't like
one of us asked the other one it was
like we have to do this so let's do it
Aria doesn't strike me as the hiking
type I was pleasantly surprised I
thought he was a little bit of a clean
boy yeah he's a little bit of a clean
boy a little bit polish rub some dirt on
there yeah I bet you already did we just
we like to click in a very unique way so
you went on both of the dates would you
decide to see either of those guys again
um excuse me
well mmm something sure okay I would
consider maybe going on another date
more open-minded than I was previously
I love how stubborn she is because she
rolled her eyes five times I love you
let me know next time
[Music]